kirby kirby kirby that's a name you
should know kirby kirby kirby he's the
star of the show he's more than you
think he's got maximum pink
kirby
that's right kirby the super tough pink
puff himself is back for an all-new 3d
adventure game and with the release date
right around the corner here's
everything to know about kirby in the
forgotten land
[Music]
kirby in the forgotten land begins with
kirby and his warp star getting sucked
into a rift in the sky transporting him
to
you guessed it a forgotten land that is
also pretty mysterious with what looks
to be abandoned structures from a past
civilization
kinda like horizon zero dawn you think
kirby will get his own focus
[Music]
anyways kirby discovers the ruins of
waddle dee town and learns that the
waddle dees are being kidnapped by the
beast pack a new group of villains
you'll be fighting in this game with
enemies as adorable as this fox-like
creature named
i love that name an enemy is as strong
and evil as the strong r b scory mondo
and the lethal leopard claraline to stop
these evildoers and rescue the waddle
dees kirby partners up with alphalin
this turquoise thing with giant ears and
sets off to suck up things and steal
abilities like kirby always does good
thing kirby is constantly put in
situations where sucking up enemies is a
useful ability otherwise he would be
screwed
kirby in the forgotten land is a 3d
platforming adventure game developed by
hal laboratory the company that's been
making kirby games since the very
beginning it's not an open world game
however it's still split up into linear
levels like previous platforming kirby
adventures each stage is a 3d
environment with hidden wattle d's to
discover and optional hidden objectives
and some of these stages include boss
fights like the two characters i
mentioned before you'll also collect
capsule toys and star coins capsule toys
are just fun collectibles and star coins
can be used in wattle d-town but more on
that later to get from level to level
there is an overworld map where you can
use the warp star to fly around and on
top of main levels there are also
treasure road levels a sort of race to
the finish style minigame where you're
given a specific copy ability or
mouthful mode and have to try and beat
the level as fast as possible each level
has a target time as well that rewards
you with more star coins if you hit it
beating these levels mainly rewards you
with rare stones which you can also use
in waddle d-town but again
more on that later one of the brand new
features in forgotten land is mouthful
mode where you can suck up objects and
take advantage of their abilities some
of the mouthful mode abilities we know
about are carmouth which turns kirby
into a car for faster traversal and to
ram into enemies vending mouth which
turns kirby into a vending machine and
gives kirby the ability to shoot cans at
enemies cone mouth which lets kirby slam
into objects using the pointy side of
the cone scissor lift mouth which gives
kirby a way to reach high places ring
mouth which unlike the doorbell shoots
out gusts of wind which can help push
boats across water or spin fans light
bulb mouth which can illuminate dark
areas arc mouth which turns kirby into a
paraglider and allows him to fly and
there's even water balloon mouth which
fills up kirby with water that can be
used to spray enemies or clean up goo
anyways that's a lot and there are
probably a whole lot more throughout the
game but i've already said a mouthful
so let's move on on top of mouthful mode
there's also the copy abilities we know
and love kirby for like sword bomb
tornado and fire however in forgotten
land you can now evolve copy abilities
for example fire can become volcano fire
and volcano fire could become dragon
fire where you can like get dragon wings
and fly around like shoot a flamethrower
out of your mouth looks pretty awesome
there's also and i'm just going to list
them off now chalk room cutter clutter
needle
gigant sword noble ranger frosty ice toy
hammer and probably so much more that
we've only seen mere glimpses of there
are also brand new copy abilities like
the drill that lets you go underground
before attacking and ranger which lets
you fire star bullets at your foes pew
pew
you can evolve your copy abilities at
the weapon shop in waddle d-town by
finding hidden blueprints throughout the
levels remember those star coins and
rare stones i mentioned earlier the
weapon shop in waddle d-town is one of
the places to use them as they're
essentially the currency needed to
evolve copy abilities after finding the
blueprints waddle d-town itself is a hub
world that grows and expands the more
waddle dees you save throughout the game
there's plenty of other things to do in
waddle d-town too like shopping
eating working at a restaurant fishing
collecting capsule toys and even
watching cutscenes again at a little
waddle d theater there's also a coliseum
you can unlock in wild with the town
where you can fight a bunch of enemies
including returning character meta
knight speaking of waddle dees and
waddle d-town the game also includes a
two-player co-op mode where the second
player can play as bandana waddle d this
ability is available very early on in
the game after the intro level so like
many other switch games you can share
the joy and pass a joy con to a friend
there are also two difficulty modes
spring breeze mode and wild mode spring
breeze mode claims to be simple to play
with a lot of health for the adventure
and the perfect mode for those new to
action games while wild mode claims to
be a bit more challenging while also
giving you more star coins as rewards
the difficulty options can be changed at
any time so feel free to try both
kirby and the forgotten land will be
exclusive to nintendo's switch and will
work on all nintendo switch models
whether you have the original the switch
light or the oled model or oled model
however you want to call it but unless
you have a separate pair of joy-cons you
won't be able to take advantage of the
two-player co-op on the switch light
since the controllers are attached to
that system so keep that in mind
kirby in the forgotten land doesn't have
any planned dlc at the moment but i'm
going to take this opportunity to talk
about the game's amiibo support because
that's kind of the physical equivalent
of dlc right anyways there aren't any
new kirby amiibo being released
alongside forgotten land but all the
curvy amiibo throughout the years are
compatible with the game including the
smash bros and kirby versions of kirby
meta knight and king dedede as well as
the waddle d amiibo and the qb amiibo
non-kirby series amiibo are also
compatible these are just the ones
highlighted by nintendo what do these
amiibo do exactly tapping non-kirby
amiibo gives you recovery items and star
coins and tapping any of the amiibo
listed above gives you even better
recovery items and even better star
coins so ultimately it's a nice bonus
for those who want it
kirby in the forgotten land launches on
march 25th 2022 for 59.99 and it'll be
available physically in stores as well
as on the nintendo eshop there is a demo
available to download right now for free
on the nintendo eshop that includes
three stages in the first world if
you're looking to try the game for
yourself before buying completing the
demo and finding all the hidden waddle
dees also gives you two present codes
that can be used in the final release at
waddle deliveries in waddle dee town
it's another cute name i really like
that name waddle dee liveries
waddle these nuts
right now there's no collector's edition
or special edition or ultra epic super
mega deluxe edition for the game however
in the u.s if you pre-order the game
from walmart you'll receive a popsocket
of kirby and if you pre-order the game
from gamestop you'll get a pin set if
you're in the uk and pre-order from the
my nintendo store you'll receive a free
notebook and magnet sheet and if you
pre-order from amazon uk you'll just get
the magnet sheet no other retailer has
announced a pre-order bonus at the time
of making this video or i missed
something and you can all yell at me in
the comments about it lucky for us more
comments means more engagement so i dare
you to do it and there you have it
everything to know about kirby and the
forgotten land thank you so much for
watching and for more on kirby in the
forgotten land you can check out the
written preview by stephen petit on our
website gamespot.com as well as 10
minutes of gameplay from the full retail
release here on our youtube channel with
a review coming soon oh and it's also
kirby's 30th anniversary this year happy
30th kirby